jedes jahr am ende des sommers finden in
köln die video days und dazu auch die
gamescom statt und dieses jahr war ich
natürlich auch wieder bei der gamescom
am start und zwar unter anderem um eine
bestimmte andere youtuber gruppe zu
treffen
youtube hatte auf der gamescom einen
stand aufgebaut mitten in einer halle wo
sich creator etwas zu trinken zu essen
nehmen konnten wo sie live streams
machen konnten und unter anderem halt
auch andere youtuber treffen konnten und
wir eventuell mitbekommen hat habe ich
dort auch einen livestream mit den
senioren socken gemacht
jedoch habe nicht nur ich diesen live
stream und das allgemeine
aufeinandertreffen gefilmt und
festgehalten und auf youtube hochgeladen
sondern auch die senioren auf ihrem
kanal und mir ist vor ein paar tagen
aufgefallen dass ich da noch gar nicht
darauf reagiert habe deswegen schauen
wir uns das jetzt mal zusammenhang ja
das ist das intro von deren video aber
zu der stelle kommen wir später meine
damen und herren die gamescom
da wollen wir doch alle hin liebe evelyn
es heißt gamescom mit nem es zwischen
dem e und dem c eigentlich sind wir ja
weniger hier unternehmen unbedingt
kennenlernen wir freuen uns schon ganz
ganz deutlich vom markt nicht
das war bissig regie ich find's schön
dass ihr mich mögt also ich mag euch
auch aber diese duschen einblendung ja
ja ja
kann ich das doch mal sehen
[Musik]
wenn ich mir das hier so angucke das ja
das ist ein hammer aus
[Musik]
du siehst ein hammer aus sehe ich jetzt
haben wir aus oder sehe ich aus wie ein
hammer
mal sehen ob sie auch in wirklichkeit ja
liebe uschi ich sehe leider nicht in
wirklichkeit aus wie ein hammer
ich sehe aus
wie ich
die wie ich halt aus her
diese so süß jetzt haben die drei also
evelyn uschi und melitta geschlafen und
bewegen sich nun zur game kommen
erkennst du nicht die gänge kommen
die gegeben kommen ja köln brück liebe
mütter und ja alle haben haben sich dann
nur auf luca gefreut ich glaube
eigentlich so gut wie niemand das war
echt hammer also ich habe die dann halt
auch getroffen in dem youtube bereich
das sehen wir gleich noch mal aber die
waren halt wirklich so mit rollator
unterwegs und ich weiß nicht ich lasse
euch jetzt mal hier ganz kurz allem wie
die anstalten auch durch die securitys
gelaufen sind mega geile aktion dass ihr
da wart also ich adressiert das jetzt
mal direkt an euch mega krass habe ich
euch ja auch schon tausend mal gesagt
dass ich das voll cool finde dass ihr
den weiten weg auf sich genommen hat das
hier vorbei geschaut habt also daumen
hoch meine omas und opas zeiten das
glaube ich nicht mitgebracht
[Musik]
also da war gab ich erkläre das ganze
mal ich hatte einen termin auf der
gamescom und zwar sollte ich mit
sebastian auf der bühne reden und danach
noch mit max und sebastian autogramme
geben und ich war sehr spät dran
deswegen musste ich da hin quasi raschen
also das ist jetzt für mich nicht
schnell raschen aber ist ja auch egal
auf jeden fall habe ich dann komplett
zufälligerweise die senioren einfach in
dem gleichen trakt getroffen wo ich auch
unterwegs war die hatten da grad ein
paar zuschauern autogramme geben und
fotos gemacht und ich musste halt
schnell weiter weil ich weiß genau wenn
ich da stehen geblieben wäre dann hätten
wir uns erst mal voll lang unterhalten
und so und ich habe all den terminen
deswegen an der stelle es tut mir leid
dass ich da nicht stehen geblieben bin
aber wir schauen wir auf die mich
überhaupt bemerkt haben ist die räder
sehen war
die haben mich gar nicht gesehen
[Musik]
ihr müsst euch einfach mal diese
komplette szenerie vorstellen das sind
drei senioren und die gamescom ist
eigentlich eine messe wo ich sag mal die
die haupt besucherzahlen irgendwie
zwischen zehn und dreißig ist oder
irgendwie so würde ich jetzt mal so ganz
grobe sagen irgendwie aber dann sitzen
die drei da in dem youtube
gaming-bereich und strampeln da im welle
warum also hammer ich kann nicht oft
genug sagen wie geil das ist nach meinem
termin mit apple auf der bühne und der
autogrammstunde mit max und sebastian
einer gamescom halle hatten wir dann ein
interview also ich mit den senioren mit
rtl und die senioren dachten dass der
rtl-moderator ich sei
[Musik]
die dachten tatsächlich dass ich
moderator sei nichts gegen den rtl
moderator der war mega cool drauf war
echt mega netter gut aber wir sehen uns
also
schaut euch mal diese szene jahren haben
die gerade realisiert dass ich nicht
diese personen dann links bin und ich
finde ich sehe dieser person noch nicht
ähnlich
also senioren ein bisschen mehr hier
hätte ich mir aber schon erwartet dann
bin ich allerdings angekommen und wie
wir uns dann begrüßt dann seht ihr jetzt
[Musik]
war aber ich will mir gesagt ich sehe
besser aus in echt als im fernsehen
aber jetzt mal talk sich so scheiße aus
meinem videos weil mir sagen dass so
viele leute in echtzeit also das soll
überhaupt nicht irgendwie eingebildet
klingen oder so sondern eher das
komplette gegenteil wenn ich leuten
begegnet bei fantreffen kommen wirklich
sehr viele an bord schießt irgendwie
ganz anders oder irgendwie viel besser
oder keine ahnung was aus als irgendwie
bei youtube
warum
ich bin nur der gleiche mensch dann
haben wir die senioren auf jeden fall
die rose geschenkt und ich hatte gar
kein geschenk dabei
ich bin
ich wäre ich ja ich bin
enkelsohn eigentlich in dem fall das war
dann auf jeden fall der leitstelle den
wir gemacht haben da haben wir minecraft
gespielt und evelyn uschi und militär
hatte ich dann jeweils verschiedene
aufgaben gegeben und wir haben geschaut
wie lange sie gebraucht haben um diese
aufgaben zu bewältigen und dann kam auch
noch max dazu und als max dann kam waren
wir auch schon so gut wie fertig mit dem
livestream doch evelyn
naja hat hat mir kein high five gegeben
[Musik]
dann ist allerdings was passiert da muss
ich ganz ehrlich sagen ich glaube das
hat ganz youtube noch nicht gesehen
bei dieser gamescom an diesem stand und
zwar habe ich ja einen livestream
gemacht und evelyn hat irgendwie die
tastenkombination gedrückt so dass der
komplette pc abgeschmiert ist samt live
stream samt spiel aber es ist einfach
selbst
ich meine schaut euch einfach mal diese
szene an
ich mein das sieht doch nicht aus als
hätten wir gerade pc kaputt gemacht dann
hat der tag auf jeden fall sein ende
gefunden
ich musste dann von der gamescom weg die
senioren sind dann glaube ich auch
irgendwann gegangen und dann haben die
allerdings in ihrem video nochmal quasi
so ein abschluss wort kundgetan der luca
und gehen hatte ich leider vergessen
aber irgendwann findet ja schon zu die
mieter wollte mir wohl ein stofftier
scharf aus minecraft schenken milliliter
dankeschön für diese geste
ich hoffe dass mich diese schafft
irgendwann noch erreichen wird und das
stimmt energierecht geschnallt wird hier
nicht
ich glaube ich das jetzt einfach mal
drin ich klatsche immer so häufig bis
sich diesen perfekten klatscher finde
wirklich bescheuert aber na ja auf jeden
fall würde ich das video an der stelle
ist auch beendet meine damen und herren
wenn ihr wollt es mal wieder auf gegen
ein anderes video reagiere sei von den
senioren zocken oder von ihnen einem
anderen kanal dann schreib mir das video
gerne in die kommentare und wenn euch
dieses video hier gefallen hat das gerne
einen like da denn bei 40.000 likes kann
man schon sagen dass die dass wir cool
sind das wasser ziehen
das war's jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocken klickten dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]